wait how so how did you save him from uh
boxing
okay so jamar been training for like
we met like three years and like oh
before that though
even before that maybe like three years
even before i even uh met you though
so training for boxing like six years he
taught himself on youtube
there you go there you go
card yeah hey bro they hit in wild card
right he's like
why did you taking a while because i
thought he can box look [ __ ]
no but here's the thing he would get in
the ring we were getting ready now he
had all that wild card
yes yeah but sometimes that's that's
dangerous man
like like going to wild card is like
doing your first set at the main room in
the comedy store
you know and be like yo you like comedy
here's the main room you're like what
the [ __ ] but he's even boxing for three
years
i'ma trust him not if he was like hey
dog i'm watching shitload of youtube no
after the fact i'm like we're gonna take
you to boxing go ahead go ahead so i
i went to uh i would go to fortune
boxing gym that was yeah ice cream
yeah and then fortune uh light like i
think they like shut down for a second i
was like i gotta get it in
and i was like [ __ ] it man i'm gonna
just go to wild card i don't know about
wild card like that i'm
trying to go to a gym [ __ ] did i come
in here the guy i had an all weight vest
i had on like weights on my feet
what can you do and he
listen he was dropped yeah yeah he gets
down
no he's in shape he's in shape so he
fooled me
something oh he must train all the time
sorry bro you want some work and i'm
like yeah yeah and he
doesn't come in but it was someone who
was green but not green
so he went in there and he survived and
then
he said you ladies gotta get that kind
of little dicey as you can see i was
like oh jamar now get out get out get
out
then i get a text like two weeks later
he was like bro if i train hard for the
next like
let's say a couple of months and i go to
mexico and build my record up you think
i got
oh no wait this is a serious question
serious
question because because at a point i
would train so much
i really just trying to just be in shape
yeah you know what i'm saying
and then so uh so i used to do the so i
did the boxing workout because i don't
want to be like buff i just want to be
like lean
shredded and then so uh i just slowly
like just start watching people around
the gym and [ __ ] like that and i
look at people and i'd be like oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
he's athletic yeah yeah yeah yeah you
hit the bags
yeah so then you talked him out of it i
talked him out i had to because i like
jamar
also but it's not like you have no other
skills yeah like if your thing was like
man
i need to do something here like you're
yeah you know what i'm saying
i got to protect this thing i got better
over time though right
and then i uh and then i thought that i
was good
and then i jumped in there with this
[ __ ] oh yeah
i didn't know that he's part everybody
like like he's part floyd mayweather
yeah
i don't know who i was in there with
is that chris tucker he's like which one
y'all
[Laughter]
yeah and then you asked me to spar yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
here's the thing he uh like so i would
get i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll jump and i'll spar with anybody i
don't go [ __ ] and then so uh
chappelle was coming and stuff and i was
like i was like chapelle man jump on in
there yeah i was like that was like
[ __ ] i'm still learning my role
i literally said that i was like let's
just try to get it
you want something
because i saw you spar like those other
dudes who've been fighting yeah
like if you if you're down to get the
ring with them what what what did rogan
tell you about fighting
yeah what do you say he's usually pretty
harsh too
okay you gotta get from from our
perspective like i actually did it now
i'm
on the outside looking in rogan sees a
ton of it
so we see how the movie ends for a lot
of these guys who do this
um okay i i was going to do the golden
globe remember i was yeah remember i was
going to do the gold in the right way
right before corona that makes sense i
was at the like oh [ __ ] let me do it
because i heard that uh martin did it
and i heard that uh
eddie murphy had did you have silver
gloves or some [ __ ] and i was like
did the uh uh the golden globe and
gloves yeah i was like well
yeah i was like oh that's that's right
there's gold
[Laughter]
the
uh there ain't no brown competition
silver [ __ ] and i said dreamcast
i got it all right i was at the like all
right well it's only right there and i
was like well then i have to do this
yeah you know like
you feel so i [ __ ] uh this [ __ ] was
training me every now and then and [ __ ]
he was like every now and then
he's going to stand up he was like have
you ever even cut weight man i was like
wait he was like yeah you got to be a
certain size then i was [ __ ] i lost
like 12 pounds in like
in like two weeks or something yeah yeah
and i walked up to rogan uh
in the um in the parking lot and i was
like rogan man i said uh i said joe i
said uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna go out for the
golden gloves and he was like wait a
minute
he was like have you ever even fought
before
i've been sparring here and there he was
like have you ever performed in front of
like a big
crowd do you get nervous and i was like
i do this joe i do stand up yeah
i'm about to go do a spot in the main
room with my shirt off you know
yeah and he was like all right man just
be careful
no i i would support you in golden
gloves
hey now you're like awake now though i
don't have the hair girl well i would
still say
i would still have your office you could
do golden gloves like all right maybe
it'd be like a fun journey to document
like that'd be cool wait so why was it
but you're trying to go to tijuana and
fight these mexican guys
but again [ __ ] how's that mal malik did
you saw he was he was so serious i get
obsessive like if i i get obsessive and
i like
i just be wanting to be like real great
at something if i'm trying and [ __ ] and
i was something like they gotta go to
mexico and knock all them [ __ ] out
yeah oh [ __ ] i just wait so what is the
golden glove
the golden gloves is a tournament like
before the trials you never heard of the
olympic trials
if you win a certain amount of golden
gloves then you qualify
for a little living then every state has
this golden glove so there's a
california golden gloves there's
colorado colorado florida
there's new york which probably new
york's probably the best golden gloves
california is big in new york it's good
your boy won the denver golden globes
okay yeah okay
let's go i won uh houston and louisiana
okay yeah
and so you were trying to go to the
olympics
no you you don't have all those you
never know [ __ ]
you never know
man i like how brittany was about to go
[Applause]
you never know i'm in colorado springs
might as well
his last words
what's the worst that could happen swear
to god i um
yeah but that's but then corona here so
i didn't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] but what i
could do
next year now what i did do was i uh i
took a i took a fight in this um
in this comedian boxing
what poor soul was there some [ __ ]
i was like this this comic hit me up
this comic hit me up he was like hey man
i heard you box
and i was at the like yeah yeah i did a
little he was like well we're having a
boxing tournament for comics he was like
you want to jump in
and i was at the like all right because
i didn't do the golden globe i was like
i'll do this [ __ ] and i was like who you
got for me
he uh [ __ ] kept turning me down it was
like no of course
all i see is that [ __ ] wear boxing
shoes
doing sets and everything that's
backstage yeah i know boxing shoes are
like my tap out shirt man
i don't know if you look so hard
i don't know so then that [ __ ] so then
this big so
they showed me this fat [ __ ] right here
right and i saw this [ __ ]
and he was just fat and out of shape and
i was like i'll get around to it
yeah right i just totally like wrote the
[ __ ] off or whatever
and uh where's it set this is uh in
goosebumps
was boxing gym and gooseman and then so
at the weigh-in at the weight i was
going to take it easy
to full on weigh-ins like i was going to
take it easy on them right
um and then like we just had to weigh in
i was like smiling and [ __ ] and doing
this
and then he posted on his instagram like
when i was smiling he was like it's all
fun and games and somebody get hit in
the mouth
and i and i took that and i took that
personally michael he talking [ __ ]
i really took that personally he could
have been talking about me but i was
like you gonna hurt me [ __ ]
so i was like let them know dog i was
hanging with my
sister you beat the [ __ ] i got real evil
i was like i was hanging on my sister i
was like all right so
how you want me to do this [ __ ] yeah
and i said do i kill him or do i just
i'll box him or what you went to hood on
him yeah
yeah [ __ ] and i was where's the video
he was not he was not ready yeah i
played he was not ready i was like yeah
i'ma just kill this [ __ ]
right so i uh and then so that [ __ ]
happened and um
it was like very [ __ ] you know how did
you feel after it the second one
i was like i gotta get better oh yeah
you wanted to he texted me right
afterwards
why is there a glove with why is there a
guy with one glove in the ring just in
case [ __ ] pops off
i think that's uh he's a choice oh
that's the ref with one glove
i ain't never boxing again i thought i
was gonna look like floyd
for your first one you're pretty [ __ ]
controlled
like you're not freaking out you're not
just grabbing wrestling oh molly taught
me that move
put your hands in the defensive [ __ ]
okay he's terrified yeah yeah yeah i
told him that when i or you're gonna see
me talking to him
and i was like what'd you say you about
to die nah i said i said are you scared
look you start complaining he said low
blow
and he's a comic yeah i guess
you can only do this to an inexperienced
[ __ ]
yeah now his form is up because he's
like leaning
right but i must say
jamar when he fights up to higher
competition he looks so much better
i seen it though but for your first
fight look pretty [ __ ] good
look this is the widest hook ever [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ]
yeah that's good that's the little
street
[ __ ] on the back of the head
yeah he wasn't ready with my roast
battle shorts on [ __ ]
that's alex phillips but that dude that
dude normally box that's my coach kyle
he doesn't
oh that was that dude's first time he's
atomic oh that was his first time ever
in the ring
yeah first another did he do that first
and i was in there with a [ __ ] that
sparred mayweather for 12 rounds
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son